welcome to the reason stream I'm Zach
Weiss Muller joined by my co-host Liz
wolf and we're both pleased to welcome
Russ Roberts to the show today he's an
economist a fellow at Stanford's Hoover
institution and host of one of my
all-time favorite podcasts econ talk we
wanted to talk to him today because he
accepted a job offer to be president of
shalm college in Jerusalem in late 2020
and mve to Israel soon thereafter we
want to get his perspective on hamas's
October 7th terrorist attack what's
unfolded since and to ask him what he
thinks of his new life in Israel Russ
Roberts thank you for talking with us
today great to be with
you what was it like for you being in
Israel on October 7th I I just want to
say first a a lot of people tell me both
here and and back in America
boy you took that job this isn't quite
what you bargain for and uh it's true uh
it's not quite what we expected when we
moved here two years two plus years ago
but I I will say that that being here
for reasons I'm sure that we'll get into
is um deeply meaningful and to be part
of History here in this moment I'm very
glad I'm here
October 7th was a a tough day many
people know it was a
Saturday um which means that people who
keep Jewish law as I do do not use their
phones or uh watch
television so uh I first found out what
was going on that day when uh I heard a
noise I actually didn't hear it because
I was in the background my my
daughter-in-law said who was visiting
daughter-in-law and son and
granddaughter were with us for over the
weekend and she said I think that's a
siren and I said yeah it is and uh she
said and then we heard uh two explosions
and she said I think that's a bomb and I
said yeah probably and she said I think
we should go to the bomb shelter and I
said yeah we should so we bundled up uh
the six of us had another family member
with us at the time and we went down to
uh around the corner there's a a bomb
shelter in a synagogue and we sat there
for a while and those two explosions we
heard were Iron Dome intercepting uh
Rockets from Gaza we're about 50 miles
from Gaza here in Jerusalem so it takes
about 90 seconds for a rocket to arrive
or at least once the siren is sounded to
get to safety so we did that I didn't
think much of it we didn't know much
about it it happened three or four more
times during the day um and we heard a
lot of rumors uh we heard that one of
the saddest moments had two very sad
moments that morning and um one was we'
heard a rumor that five people have been
kidnapped we were just horrified at that
thought of course we later found out it
was more like
240 uh the second sad thing was that uh
someone in in the say I said I I'll be
back in a minute to me and he went
downstairs to say goodbye to his son who
was on his way to the front uh so that
day uh thousands of reservists uh were
called up uh the Army was mobilized it
took a tragically long time to get the
Army down to the Gaza area uh where uh
inside Israel where the attacks took
place uh and of course uh Israelis all
over the world streamed back um over
100% of the requests for
people on reserve duty uh were filled
more than meaning they demanded and
asked for people to come and many many
more answered the call and over 100,000
Israelis overseas just came back to face
danger and it's a precious thing about
this place that there's a loyalty and a
sense of national pride uh that that's
the case you probably also know that
before October 7th this country was
close to Civil War I don't use that
phrase lightly there was an
extraordinarily
divisive uh issue of judicial reform on
the table which we could talk about if
you want but not so important with
respect to October 7th other than uh
Pilots had refused to
train uh during this time as as as time
went on and the and the judicial reform
remained on the table uh there were
skirmishes and scuffles between people
of different viewpoints encounter
protests protests and counter protests
and uh there were a lot of people
thinking that Israel was falling apart
that people were going to be at each
other's throats and a lot of people
would be leaving uh especially people
from the high-tech sector which is the
backbone of the economy here uh October
7th changed everything in an instant um
it's an extraordinary amount of
cooperation love and unity between left
and right between secular and religion
um it's an extraordinary moment in this
country's
history October 8th meaning the day
after this war whenever that
comes um I think will be very
challenging again but for now the amount
of resolve is
extraordinary and unity how much
internal rage would you say there is um
related to Israeli intelligence failures
the fact that this was such a surprise
yeah so the um the you know the prime
minister is is uh Benjamin Netanyahu
who's called BB here that's his
nickname uh he's been a very uh
important figure in Israeli history over
the last three decades um everything
from uh economic reforms that he
spearheaded uh dealing with all kinds of
National Security threats but in the
months leading up to this event he is
increasingly a polarizing figure for
most people here there's still people
who love him very much but a lot of
people uh dislike him and I would say
dislike him very similarly to the way
that people dislike Donald Trump in
America the ones who do similarly in
America people love Donald Trump and
hate him there aren't that many people
in between BB is similarly uh polarizing
here and so uh there's a lot of anger
that
one uh we were surprised by the attack
two that we were slow to respond slow
meaning hours rather than closer to
minutes um and there's a lot of anger
that that political issue of judicial
reform remained on the table despite the
anger and uh animosity that it generated
there's two sides to that issue you can
argue you know in favor of it against it
it's a very interesting issue but
clearly the country was uh divided by it
and there were many many people from the
military and the security World here who
said this is bad for us we need to stop
it uh and resolve this controversy
because we are vulnerable and so um
there's a lot of anger about that uh I
am moved by how little rage there is
here or blood Lust For revenge against
Hamas there is a lot of what I call
resolve that it has to change uh the
situation has to change but um people
here are surpris to my view given what
happen surprisingly calm certainly a lot
of anger uh toward Hamas and and the
monstrosities that were committed but a
lot of shock
uh
despair uh
mourning and um it's a it's an emotional
roller coaster to to summarize it for me
living here there are days where I'm
incredibly sad about how hard it's going
to be for this to turn out well and
there are days where I'm you know
extremely
um uh moved and inspired by the
opportunity to be part of the response
to to this challenge uh this country has
pulled together in a way that you know
was never visible in America in my
lifetime even in the aftermath of
911 it unless you're here you really
can't appreciate how much every single
person is doing something to either help
the troops or the people whove now are
refugees because their homes were
destroyed burned down or made
uninhabitable by the attacks or the
people been evacuated from the north out
of fear of an attack from Lebanon and
Hezbollah uh there's there's tens of
thousands of people rooming here in
Jerusalem temporarily and there's an
army of Civil
Society the government's missing an
action partly because of disorganization
partly because of speed partly for a
whole bunch of reasons and the way that
the so-called private sector I don't
like that phrase what I would call Civil
Society volunteerism and uh people just
solving problems is u extraordinarily
beautiful and it's happening with
provisioning of the military um we have
a staff member who drives three times a
week and she cooks hot meals for the
soldiers and I said well how many meals
do you make she said about 2,000 a day
what where you get the food oh well this
organization delivers the food an hour
before we get there we never know what
it's going to be and then they we decide
what we're going to make it's eight
people and uh she works there so she
delivers with the food articles by her
faculty at shm college and ask if they
want a lecture and we've been sending
out lectures to give talks on the Middle
East and on Islam and on Hezbollah and
on David and Goliath and everything you
can possibly imagine but I said why why
are you doing this don't doesn't the
Army give our soldiers food she said
yeah but it's sometimes just a sandwich
and if you're going into combat you
should have a hot meal well that's
reasonable okay and there's no there's
no field kitchen next to Gaza so this is
effectively a field kitchen and God
bless her and there's a that's happening
uh for again for the displaced families
it's happening for the the refugees and
evacuees and it's um it's really
beautiful the there's a weird sort of
irony there that the is the Israel that
you're describing before October 7th was
highly divided and now this terrorist
attack has unified them unified Israelis
uh I I have to assum that's not a
strategic win for Hamas and definitely a
strike against the strategy of terrorism
putting aside the obvious immorality of
it yeah I'm you know you you mentioned
that you are about 50 miles from Gaza a
90 second rocket trip you know moving
from the United States where you you
don't live under that constant uh you
know you know ticking clock in your mind
like I got 90 seconds like what how does
that affect you as a person to move into
that situation yeah um I'll try to say a
couple things about that um first of all
the the woman I mentioned who does the
cooking of the 200000 meals uh they have
20 seconds there not 90 because they're
closer to Gaza
um um I wrote a piece about the first
day of the war and
there are different Sirens here there's
a siren that goes off on um Memorial Day
for the Fallen Soldiers and there's a
siren that goes off Friday afternoon for
the coming of the Sabbath and there's a
siren that goes off for yum hasah which
is the day commemorating the victims of
the
Holocaust those last the Memorial Day
and the Holocaust one they last two
minutes every
Israeli gets out of their car or stops
in the street and stands in silence very
moving uh I know what those sound like
they're a a long high tone that that
blares and and goes for a few
minutes this one wasn't like that
um it was an aid siren and I've never
heard one before as you said lived my
life in the United States never been
attacked by a rocket and but I've seen
enough movies about World War II so I I
knew what it what it sounded like and
um what's you know since that first day
where we had three or four maybe five
um none of them did any damage they were
all intercepted by Iron Dome or were
left to hit the ground Iron Dome our
surveillance system tries to project
where they're going to land then if it's
going to be a field we just we iron DS
very expensive so we don't we don't
shoot things down if we don't think
they're going to hurt anybody um we have
other air defense systems here we have
Arrow which shoots down ballistic
missiles we shot down a ballistic
missile shot shot from Yemen the other
day there's work on a laser
um but there only been since that first
day probably three or so four maybe
Sirens over the last
month and so it's pretty peaceful here
right now there was a lot of
apprehension in Jerusalem anyway it's
pretty it's not the case in Tel Aviv or
outside of uh Gaza there's still quite a
few Rockets being launched every single
day but D's fairly quiet uh there is
some residual anxiety here that
Hezbollah would enter the war doesn't
look like it um for a variety reasons we
can talk about but assuming they that
they don't uh that's really great
because they have much bigger rockets
that are much more accurate so and they
have about 150,000 supposedly stockpiled
so that uh is and then maybe Oran will
get in the war so
the uh hanging in the back of your mind
is some
unease
um and I think it takes a toll on a
person the other thing I think that's
hard is that you know every almost
everybody I know has a a a kid or a
relative in the reserves who's now at
the front or near the front or at the
front of Lebanon
uh I have a great nephew here um but
many people have my colleague down the
hall has a a son and her husband are
both in uniform and not home so uh the
the anxiety that these people are
experiencing and the realization that is
heartbreaking that if they do come home
they will not be the same person because
of what they've seen and had to do which
um is is very sad it's just I think it
it weighs on you in a way you don't
you're not aware of so I find myself uh
you know being a little bit
short-tempered
or down and I'm thinking why am I down
it's because there things to be down
down about but um as I said it's a bit
of a roller coaster there are many many
times when I'm um just uh life's very
meaningful here and very purposeful in
this in this time and we're able
fortunately because we're such a small
College to mobilize our resources both
for the troops and the refugees and for
our students our alumni we're doing all
kinds of programming and we're
partnering with organizations to help
them uh provide food and shelter for the
refugees evacuees medical supplies for
the troops they don't have so it's um
it's very meaningful so I'm uh mostly up
but sometimes down this reminds me so
much of something you wrote in your book
um and I believe Zach has a an excerpt
but you say something along the lines of
you initially weren't interested in this
role being the president of this college
in Jerusalem and uprooting your life and
moving to Israel and that on I guess the
the quote is on narrow utilitarian
grounds this was a no-brainer only a
fool would take the job but then you
talk about the idea of this on many
other grounds bringing you closer to who
you want to be and I'm very curious
about how has October 7th played into
that how do you find yourself relating
to jewishness to toward your either
cultural Identity or or religious one as
a result of not only taking this job and
moving to Israel but specifically after
October 7th how has this changed you
well first thing I'd say is how it's
changed others and then I'll bring it
back to to me
um Israel is a has a wide very diverse
uh set of views on religion among its
citizens we have the so-called Ultra
Orthodox uh we have the purely secular
and we have every flavor in between
including many many people who follow
Jewish tradition but without the
intensity or uh Precision say of the
alter Orthodox but it's an important
part of their life and before October
7th as I alluded to in passing there was
there was quite a bit of um tension
between the religious right and the
secular left uh brought to this brought
to the surface by this issue of judicial
reform because the two groups split very
cleanly on that issue the religious
right was much more in favor of it and
the secular left was very much against
it and that was part of what was ripping
this country apart uh any willingness of
non-religious people to be part of the
jewishness of the state rather than just
a mere say identity was nil they just
didn't want any part of it uh most Ultra
Orthodox people here do not serve in the
Army are subsidized in various ways this
creates resentment uh I think it's
terrible policy it's driven by the
politics and the strange nature of the
Israeli political system but that's the
reality and it it had created quite a
bit of resentment uh between these two
groups so the war
comes and thousands of alter Orthodox
volunteer unexpectedly I think to the
surprise of of the secular part of the
society they volunteer and are they've
they train for about three weeks they've
been now now they're quote battle ready
I don't know what they're going to be
doing but their their basic training was
quite brief but they are in the Army and
ready to do
something um and that's on that side the
other side is there's been an enormous
outpouring
of religious feeling on the part of the
non-religious uh there are no atheists
in a foxhole obviously at a time of War
people turned to the Transcendent to the
spiritual to the Divine for help in
either coping with it or getting
strength and the amount of ritual
observance that has taken
place um is just it's very very powerful
and it's um I don't know what it's long
run implications will be but uh many
people have observed that everything's
going to be different here after this
war ends especially our political system
especially our view of ourselves as Jews
and especially our views Vis of the
Palestinian people either in Gaza or the
West Bank and we could talk about any of
those if you want but on the Jewish
issue for me
um I never planned to live in Israel I
never dreamed many people do many Jews
dreamed to to move to Israel at some
point in their life I didn't but when
the job came along I as as you described
in the book I certainly was excited
about the opportunity not at first as I
wrote but eventually came to embrace it
and feel like it was something I was
meant to do you know being here at this
time uh when I took the job I think I
accepted the job around um fall of
2020 and I couldn't come for a while
because it was coid and I couldn't get
there were a whole bunch of things I
needed to get taken care of to be able
to become an Israeli citizen FBI
background checks Visa issues birth
certificate all complicated stuff so I
had to wait and while I was waiting in
the spring of 2021 Israel was attacked
by Hamas the October 6th was the was in
the ceasefire that was agreed to the
last time uh Hamas attacked and I
remember feeling in then it was you know
March I think of 2021 and I didn't get
here till June but I remember feeling in
March or April whenever it was or may GE
I wish I could be there uh it's a little
scary of course but it feels like I want
to be part of it well I'm here now I'm
part of it now and
um um I'm I'm really glad uh the to have
the chance to be part of this
organization shalm College which is
working
to help both the troops and are alumni
in the Army and the vac evacuees and
refugees it's just it's a wonderful
thing I'm really proud to be part of it
in any way my heer is not very good it
limits my ability to completely uh
contribute but um it feels like I belong
here to be part of this and I'm very
very glad I am what you're talking about
with sorry Zach I'll I'll let you go in
a sec what you're talking about though
with secular Jews becoming more in touch
with with Judaism as a as a religion uh
it's crazy that you said that because I
think that this is also having Ripple
effects in other places with huge Jewish
populations like New York I was
literally sitting at a bar before a
reason event last night with two friends
one of whom was sort of a secular you
know has been a secular Jew his entire
life and he was talking you know very um
personally about how he feels the need
to go to Israel now he wants to take his
fiance to Israel he feels this sense of
he was asking us because he knows my
other friend host Passover even though
she's not Jewish um and he's just like
can I can I come can I come now um so
what you're saying I think is so true
you know probably most intensely felt in
Israel but it's interesting seeing even
all of these Ripple effects uh in juice
all around the world yeah it's a great
it's a great observation and I
think the other thing that's happening
certainly is that you know when this war
broke out my kids who are not here were
all worried about me and my family was
worried about me and they would call and
I try to call my mom every day just to
say she's in um Alabama I try just let
her know I'm fine and I didn't die again
it's very safe here but she's my mom and
she's worried so I understand that um
but after a while I started being more
worried about them than I think they
were about me as we saw a rise in
anti-Semitism and actually don't like to
call it that I I Jew hatred it's pretty
pretty blunt and um it's very old and we
kind of like to Hope and think it's gone
away but it is back uh a day or two
after the attacks of October 7th there
was a rally on the steps of the Sydney
Opera House where a pro
Palestinian rally ended with uh gas a
chant of gas the Jews it's a little bit
uh hard to believe that that happens in
2023 but people have tragically been
killed now in the aftermath math of
October 7th in the Jewish communities
around the world um and there's a lot of
anger obviously on both sides I'm very
very apprehensive about the uh the
future especially on college campuses
where Jews have been at times afraid for
their lives uh in the presence of
rallies and other things the tearing
down of the the posters of uh kidnapped
children and kidnapped adults I don't
think that's that big a deal what is
disturbing to me more is the fact that
they seem to enjoy it uh they get
pleasure from tearing them down I could
understand a lot of different reasons
you might not want to look at them but
to enjoy tearing them down seems very
dark but I think your point Li that many
Jews around the world are suddenly
feeling a deep
identification uh with their Judaism and
with Israel which really was has been on
the Wayan for quite some time I think
among the diaspora among Jews outside of
Israel the last thing I'll say is that
um
even though this is not a religious
State the
uh it's not a theocracy but Judaism does
permeate many aspects of life here uh
and some are quite uh create quite a bit
of friction uh the the the rabbis here
do have control over say marriage and
certain issues that are very
controversial there ways of getting
around it people found them and it's
it's but it's resented in many many ways
and
understandably so um having said that
the Bible the the Hebrews Hebrew Bible
and Jewish practice and tradition
permeate all of Israeli culture even
when it's not religious so it's sitting
there waiting to be picked up for people
who want to embrace it uh you know
traditional Jewish liturgy gets turned
into a pop song that becomes a great hit
reg even though it's the religiousness
of it isn't doesn't speak to people they
still fall in love with it and all kinds
of phrases from the Bible or the tomwood
are part of Israeli slang and jargon and
culture so what's been interesting on I
was trying to give you a feel for which
is hard to do with the videos is how
many uh secular Jews here have embraced
some taste of that uh because it's our
heritage whether it's a religious f or
not it is the you know thousands of year
old Heritage of this land and everybody
who lives here uh can access it if they
want I mean just to take an
example you probably know that uh that
about 2,000 years ago a bunch of Jewish
Rebels took a stand on a mountain
against the Roman Empire and that place
is called
Masada uh and you can go visited it's a
it's a uh a a Hilltop Plateau like a
Mesa and uh it was The Last Stand of a a
bunch of uh Jewish Rebels against the
Roman State and um according to Josephus
historically I'm not sure it's true you
know they they they fought uh bravely
for for a long time and then
finally Ro the Roman army encircled the
place cut them off from food and water
and slowly starved him to death until uh
finally uh they all committed suicide uh
on mass so that they would not be uh uh
butchered or or abused by the Romans in
defeat and it's probably not 100% true
because
um
who survived to tell that historical
detail if they all killed themselves but
Josephus writes about it in um in his
book that I think the Jewish
Wars uh so that's interesting and you
can go to Mada you can climb it it's a
it's very warm hot there it's in the uh
it's in the desert near the Dead Sea
very near to where the Dead Sea Scrolls
were found um and it's an extremely
interesting archaeological site but it's
also the place where the Israeli Army
swears in many of its units in uh memory
of that fight against Rome and to have
that you know tradition is
um it's very rich and it's it it's it
pervades all kinds of parts of the
culture here in ways that you'd have to
be here to fully uh
appreciate Russ you mentioned the
reactions around the world the tearing
of the posters this incident at the
Sydney Opera house and we we have a clip
of we've pulled the clip from that
incident with which as horrible as it is
I do want to play just to have people
absorb it and also because it sparked a
tweet thread of it partially sparked a
tweet thread of yours that I want to
discuss with you okay so let's roll a
little bit of that
clip
[Music]
I mean it is just shocking to see this
happening in a place like Australia and
I am curious if seeing these kind of
reactions in you know I don't know
English-speaking countries uh has
changed your political views at all you
you posted this thread on October 25th
saying that the the beginning of the
thread you write that the aftermath of
October 7th is a test for the west and
for all open societies societies that
nominally believe in freedom of speech
and the press such societies are now at
a Crossroads and must must think about
the direction they wish to head what do
you do about this kind of Jew hatred um
I'll just pose that question back to you
here what do you think an open and free
Society should do in the face of the
kind of hatred and vitri all we see on
display in that
clip so well I call that I I eventually
wrote an essay on this I called it the
Dilemma of the West uh because I don't
think there's an easy answer to
it all my life I've been a very uh
passionate advocate for freedom of
speech freedom of press and I said
nominally respecting freedom of speech
and press because obviously over the
last five years or so eight years or so
10 years in America and elsewhere
freedom of speech has been under attack
and uh that's been deeply disturbing to
me uh both
freedom of speech both as a um as a
cultural
norm and often sometimes as an actual
regulation there have been attempts to
curtail speech curtail opinions that
made people uncomfortable and certainly
culturally using norms and and
non-governmental methods to uh reduce
honesty on the part of people about what
they really think and feel and I think
that's you know very bad and uh a few
people still agree with me on that but
it's surprising how much in American in
the west that is a controversial
opinion um at the same time uh do we
make any distinction this is what what I
was trying to ask in that Twitter thread
and in the essay do we want to make any
distinction between say unpopular
political
opinions and um Jew hatred racism uh
exhortations to
violence
um I would make a distinction between
writing and rallying uh the thing I find
disturbing about the rallying and the
thing I find disturbing about the
tearing down of the posters is there's a
implicit threat of violence behind
them um In that clip you just showed you
know my um arabic's not what he used to
but I think those are uh Jihad flags
being waved uh where Jihad is about
killing infidels um
and I you know what do you do about that
do you just say well that's their
opinion we don't agree with it
um the way that the
Sydney city of Sydney dealt with that
rally is they told Jews to stay away
from the Sydney Opera House and if you
look at that clip
carefully not carefully just look at it
the second time you'll see policemen in
reflective S standing on the the um
steps there in the background watching
this I I don't know what else one could
do do uh besides watch it I'm not
suggesting that that that they should
storm the group for saying what they
said um and you know and it really I
don't think there's an
easy way to deal with this um I Ed the
other example in that essay that
uh at some I think pro-israel rally
there was a group of of Jews who
conducted an evening prayer service it
was it was a very small group maybe 15
people saying the evening prayer service
but nearby was either a pro Palestinian
Rally
or uh an an a response to the pro-israel
rally a police barricade there and there
were dozens maybe hundreds of people
shouting free Palestine while these Jews
were trying to say their evening prayers
and you know what do we say about that
do we say that's just protest do we do
make a distinction between a public
space and a private space so for example
if uh people want to hold a
um a rally on behalf of either Palestine
or Israel in a college campus meeting
room do people have the freedom should
they have the freedom to chant things in
response to that and you know it really
is a tragically beautiful example of how
difficult it is
to
legislate kindness a lot of what
underlies uh the American culture
of trust of discourse of searching for
the truth of mutual respect is
inherently cultural it's not legislated
you can't legislate it and when it
disappears attempts to legislate it are
not going to work so I don't think
there's a simple attractive magic answer
to how do you deal with speech that is
um
violent uh how do you deal with a March
that has violence around it and just to
leave I'll finish with talking about the
posters uh what's depressed me watching
it from a distance here in Israel is how
many people when they film the folks
tearing down the posters beg them to
stop and beg them to explain themselves
why are you doing this they cry out and
that's the tone it's it's it's a it's a
begging instead of saying uh I don't
approve of that and to stand in their
way and many of you watching this I'm
sure saw the clip of the New York
construction worker who got in the face
of someone tearing down the posters and
said this is America you don't do that
and I'm not going to let you and
intimidated the guy very very uh uh
unattractively to to get him to stop but
what's the alternative and the current
alternative which I don't particularly
like is of taking photos of these of
these people and and identifying them
and trying to get them fired and you
know I don't think somebody should be
fired for a moment of emotional response
to a kidnapped child that maybe makes
them uncomfortable for a thousand
reasons and but how do we handle that as
a society it's not an easy question yeah
so one thing I wanted to ask you about
that is there's the cultural component
which you alluded to there at the end
with should there be social consequences
for tearing down a a poster of someone
who's been abducted or yelling something
horrible like Gass the Jews at a protest
I would say certainly the latter I would
not want to employ someone who was in
that video uh but then there's the
question the very just real you know
political question of should this be
allowed um and is it it is there
something insufficient about just the
the straightforward liberal or
libertarian framework
of you have to allow the bad speech
particularly in a in a public space to
take place and you draw the line at
actual violence not really nasty words
you know we tolerate for instance
famously here the westbo Baptist Church
saying horrible things on public grounds
outside of funerals I mean you can't
imagine something much worse than that
and kind of the cultural response has
been like these gangs of motorcycle
these motorcycle gangs follow them
around and like drown them out with the
motorcycle so there's cultural response
but they they prot Ed in their speech is
there something that's not sufficient in
that that framework for this particular
problem in your opinion well I want to I
want to bring in something I heard from
Tom Palmer who you may know uh from uh
Atlas uh and who is a longtime friend of
mine I don't remember when this was it
decades ago I got into an argument with
Tom about freedom of speech and I you
know I said I don't like that the Nazis
marched in scope
for example ski is a Jewish neighborhood
M uh suburb of Chicago and the Nazis
March through the streets of skoki and
um someone recently pointed out to me
yeah there were about two dozen of them
if there had been 100,000 maybe you'd
feel differently about that March but I
said at the time they have a right to
March I'm I can never we can never know
what where truth is in a democracy the
whole beauty of freedom of speech is to
allow diverse viewpoints to be expressed
peacefully uh and Tom didn't agree with
that Tom felt very strongly and I'm sure
he still does and I starting to think
he's right that freedom of speech should
not be allowed by people for people who
don't believe in freedom of speech that
is if you are part of the Nazis or the
Communists and I would put it Hamas in
with this also which is a a grou Tes
Theocratic death cult um it doesn't
believe in freedom of speech I'll just
put a footnote here that story came out
yesterday that that there were a bunch
of photographers and journalists who
went with Hamas on October 7th through
the Gap in the fence and chronicled and
photographed the atrocities and that
this was an ethical violation and I'm
thinking do you really think there are
any journalists in Gaza do you really
native journalist do you really think
there are people who live in Gaza who
can report who can tell the truth who
can say critical things about a Kamas of
course there aren't of course everyone
there will at least say that they
support Hamas and will act accordingly
they do not hold by the journalistic
standards that we like to think uh other
journalists hold by and New York Times
had a slight Challenge on this they had
a a a journalist there that they used as
a Stringer who admires Hitler and had
posted on on social media how great
Hitler was but the times assured us that
he really reported very objectively as
if you could possibly know so the these
kind of
insane um situations where you're
granting rights and freedoms to people
who would be thrilled to either slit
your throat or take those freedoms away
from you seems a
bit strange and so Tom's view was if the
go of not any individual because that's
we don't can't measure it and it's hard
to to assess and who knows but
organizations that have as their
Charter the the Revolutionary desire to
take away freedoms from other people
should not be given those freedoms and
although it's hard for me to say that to
agree with them I think he's probably
right so any one protester might let
them say there say from The River To The
Sea even though that means killing me
and my friends here uh and and ending
the Jewish State um I I would probably
let them say that or or put it in a say
it in a classroom but an organization
that wants that believes in that or that
believes in in in gassing jewes or
murdering Jews or any other group should
probably not be
given the same rights to express
themselves
as other groups uh maybe they shouldn't
be given a a permit to walk on the
streets of skoki I'm in I'm in Florida
and the governor here has just uh
attempted to ban student groups that are
supportive of Palestine on the pretense
that they say that they're in alignment
with what happened in Gaza and therefore
he's saying they're providing material
support to them um I honestly you know
even though I find that repugnant I find
it I also find it disturbing as a
gubernatorial action to and like a very
clear example of how once you start
saying well they are somehow affiliated
with a group that is murderous that they
themselves don't have a right to express
all these other views on a campus so
that is the the part of my concern with
what you're saying even though I I
acknowledge a very problem I agree with
you I I do not think let me let me be
clear about a couple things um Israel
makes lots of mistakes does some
horrific things I'm not proud of them
I'm ashamed of them don't want them to
continue um uh we could debate what
those might be I do not think um the
current ground defensive in Gaza is
anything to be ashamed of I think it's
morally appropriate and although
tragically I'm sure thousands perhaps of
civilians have died in Gaza which is
horrible and um and a tragedy Israel
gave them weeks to to leave and Hamas at
the point of a gun wouldn't let many of
them leave so I hold Hamas responsible
for that having said that Israel's done
plenty of horrific things to
Palestinians in Gaza Palestinians in the
West Bank and it's perfectly legitimate
to be opposed to Israeli policies it's
perfectly legitimate to support a
Palestinian State it's perfectly
legitimate to fight for the rights of
Palestinians say to water rights or to
fight for their ability to get better
police protection or you fill in the
blank there plenty of things that you
can be Pro Palestine about without being
anti-jew uh but if you're anti-jew it
seems to be crossing a line
so groups that are pro Palestinian
should be allowed on college campuses
and elsewhere in my view uh as long as
it doesn't shade into the celebration of
murdering people which seems like
crossing a line now they would disagree
by the way and to be fair to them you
know at these Pro Palestine rallies in
say London where 100,000 people marched
many of them chanting from the river to
the sea or free Palestine which does not
mean um rights for Palestinians it means
the land that Israel's on now should
belong to um the Palestinians and not to
the to the Jewish
State uh they also say things like by
any means necessary and of course
they're an underdog and they don't have
a good military and of course they're
blockaded from getting military weapons
not perfectly successfully but so
perhaps you can make the case that they
have to use means that others would not
stomach I guess for me it's mainly the
enjoying of it that's so disturbing um
but the thing that I get into with this
because obviously I completely agree I
mean watching this happen we've seen a
lot of this in New York there's there's
an astonishing like odiousness to this
action of of tearing down the posters of
kidnapped children you know so many
people have tried to make the point that
these posters are pointless um that you
know these people what's the point in
spreading images of their faces and
what's the point in spreading their
names if you know we know where they are
it's not New York they're not going to
be found here what use is it in having
Manhattan commuters see these names as
they walk to work and so you know
there's the parallel drawn between the
posters of missing people after 9911
that were put up where it's like those
people aren't going to be found those
people died in 911 and it was an
expressive act it's a political
statement it's a don't let this um you
know when you're going about your
mundane everyday life don't let this
fade uh make sure that this remains sort
of seared into your memory for a longer
time even than you feel comfortable with
it's it's an it's an expressive act
putting up these posters but the thing
that I'm curious about because you've
referred to it a few times in in this
conversation and in the thread is how
how should we read the tearing down of
the posters is it a tacit endorsement of
hamas's actions and of the kidnapping of
children or is it so frequently
this unthinking
act that is an attempt
to you know distract from the horrors
committed but isn't something like it's
hard for me to when I think about other
forms of excuse my friends but like
[__] campus activism I think about
how so much of this calls to abolish the
police for example these are unthinking
calls frequently I don't think that
there is actually you know when you
press people on this they say oh well
actually you know we don't want to
abolish the police um there's 's a lot
of hedging that happens there's almost
this um you know walking back of the
claims should we actually be
interpreting people pulling down these
posters of hamas's kidnapped uh and and
victims should we actually be
interpreting this as a Taca endorsement
of this or should we be interpreting it
as something different no I would not I
don't interpret it that way that's why I
said I hope I made it clear that uh I
don't think there's anything criminal
about tearing down tearing it down I
don't even think there's necess
necessarily anything thoughtless or
cruel about it or endorsement of of the
of the ACT but sometimes it is uh you
know that that's the problem and and I'm
that's why one of the reasons I'm so
uncomfortable with cancelling these
people I don't know what exactly they're
thinking um and uh although sometimes
they tell
you they will sometimes say you know uh
Hitler was great in which case I G to go
with the I think there it's a tested
approval but but a lot of times could
that example that you cited of the New
York Times um was so interesting because
the times also claimed that having
uncovered these Hitler praising posts
from years ago that don't worry they
sort of like re-educated this they they
had a talking to with him and it sort of
shows the holess of like do you actually
think that an HR session is what it
takes to get somebody to reverse course
on praising Hitler he went to a workshop
everything's fine now um but but the I I
think you rais a bunch of interesting
points about the posters and it forces
you
um it's all interesting to me I walk to
work every day and
today about a five minute walk from my
house there was a stroller parked next
to a park bench and stroller was empty
other than a sign of a kidnapped child
and a prayer for returning of
captives um and then I saw a second one
about 25 yards further further down the
hill I came to work here on our campus
we share with the Jewish agency which is
a organization that helps people move to
Israel and does a bunch of other things
but there's a large Courtyard here near
my building and that courtyard we use
for graduation it's a place of
Celebration I have wonderful memories of
that courtyard and right now there's a
there's a uh table set for 240 in that
courtyard uh with empty seats and um
posters on each chair and I don't think
that's there to get me to do something
to bring them home I don't think there's
anything I can do to bring them home I
think it's there as you say to remind us
that there are people around us who are
grieving who are having unimaginable
pain that the world is a difficult place
there are many many things about that
kind of uh expressive art if you would
uh that that are worth enduring and
experiencing and at the same time you
can't think about it 247 you go you're
going to your heart will break and
you'll won't be able to function so
those who tear them down I think some of
them don't like to look at it they don't
want to be reminded they don't want to
think about it others have convinced
themselves it didn't happen uh it's not
true and they see it as some kind of
conspiracy so I think there are many
many responses that human beings can
have to that kind of thing and I think
the power of freedom of speech is that
you're supposed to hear all kinds of
different views and try to get smarter
by hearing what the basis is for those
different views and that's the idea I'm
not sure it's true um you know this this
moment so many people know exactly what
the right thing to do and feel is and
can't imagine anyone could feel any
differently and the idea that someone on
the other side from us could feel
equally strongly equally righteous and
equally moral is unimaginable and yet
that's the way they feel uh now they're
welcome to feel that way sometimes your
life's at stake or you're safety and you
it's a luxury to give them the benefit
of the doubt but that's the reality
we're in on you know on social media
right now is that there there are many
decent there are a lot of wicked people
on social media but there's a lot of
decent people on both sides who are
suddenly very sure of themselves and
that would include me I I feel it you
know all the time uh how can that person
not see that fill in the blank and it's
a good good lesson to be aware that you
might be wrong you you mentioned a
little bit of doubt about I guess the
concept of the the marketplace of ideas
and whether you know the people will
really will arrive it at something
approximating Truth by them going
head-to-head um but you know one one
concept within that framework is the
chilling effect like if there is if
there are too much
whether they're political consequences
or just social consequences for engaging
in certain kinds of discourse that there
will be a chilling effect and like legit
you know the legitimate issues that that
you alluded to that pales that
Palestinians might have could get could
get buried um you know one of one of the
high profile examples that I wanted to
get your thoughts on was what happened
with representative Rashida TB she
became the 26th member in Congressional
history to be censured in part for uh
well in part for a tweet she made that
was jumping to the conclusion that
Israel bombed a hospital when in fact it
was a rocket that Hamas misfired and
then she didn't really make any effort
whatsoever to correct that a the rocket
was technically not fired by Hamas but
an Allied group with Hamas yeah the uh
Islamic Jihad I think but yeah thank you
for that
clarification and um t uh released this
statement uh on October 8th so the day
after the attack of kind of tellingly
titled on ongoing violence in Israel and
Palestine where she says I grief the
Palestinian and Israeli lives lost
yesterday today and every day I am
determined as ever to fight for a just
future where everyone could live in
peace the past to that future must
include lifting the blockade ending the
occupation and dismantling the apar
system that creates the suffocating
dehumanizing conditions that can lead to
resistance and her characterizing this a
this action as resistance was cited as a
reason to censure
her does that statement strike you as
beyond the pale and worthy of
censure uh well first of all it's an
offensive statement it offends because
it it implies that what happened on
October 7th was justified it was the
unex UN inevitable result of the
behavior of of Israel and how it treats
the
Palestinians I don't like the use of the
word aparte there were two million Arabs
who live in Israel who have
free healthc care College can vote um
it's not free totally but it's free
healthare but they have the same health
care that every Israeli has they have
the same educational system as every
Israeli they have equal rights um so
calling this an apartheid situation I
find offensive just as I find offensive
the phrase genocide the population in
West Bank and Gaza has risen five-fold
over the last I think five or six
decades if this genocide were not very
good at it
uh the phrase allows a comparison of
Israel to the Nazis just I don't find
that helpful or honest having said that
uh I don't have any problem with that
statement uh I would not have censured
her I don't think it's good for the Jews
that we cented her um not sure it's good
for Israel and I want to say one other
thing uh before you say that could you
tell me why you say that about why is it
not good for the Jews or Israel to
Center her like the idea that we we're
so powerful we can you know get a
congress member of Congress censured
because she said something that we don't
like I that's the way it's easily
interpreted I I'm sure if there were no
Jews in Congress and no Jews in America
it's possible she would have been
censured e either way but I don't think
it looks so good to be clear there were
Jewish members of Congress who voted to
censure her and to not censure her so
correct there's not really too much
there substantively but I understand per
it does it's the same reason I don't
like I don't think it's good for for
Jews that we get these people fired or
teared down the posters it's like just
makes people angry at the Jews who
already don't like them we have to stand
up for our I much rather stand up and
block the poster Ripper than than to use
the legal system or or other things to
to punish them unex in ways they can't
anticipate which is also I think unjust
um but I I want to say something I think
important about about say Congressional
uh Speech and um it's a perfectly
legitimate
opinion to to oppose American military
aid to Israel on the grounds that Israel
is treats the Palestinians poorly I
don't agree with the the the the
justification but I'm not sure American
Aid is always good for Israel so
strategically and in terms of making the
world a better place it's a complicated
question but it certainly should be
protected by free speech to say that
American support for Israel is wrong uh
that that that is and and
fundamentally it would be grotesque to
censure people who didn't want to stand
by Israel in this particular moment and
who feel that uh the Palestinian cause
has been in inaccurately presented or
distorted or anything so I I want to be
clear I don't I don't think Israel's
entitled or Jews are entitled to any
special treatment in this moment because
of the horrific nature or Savage and
barbaric nature of October 7th I just
think we should get the same treatment
as everybody else um but that in general
I'm I remain a fan of Free Speech but I
do think uh exhorting people to violence
might fall into a different grw
different category I do think it's also
worth sort of bringing into the
conversation that like censoring a
member of Congress doesn't actually do
anything it is essentially a formal a
formalized means of slapping somebody on
the wrist uh yeah absolutely and and
much of what we're talking about here is
is virtue signaling of various kinds
that I find unhealthy for for democracy
um I would much rather she get voted out
of office if her constituents find her
offensive or disagree with her and
that's the way a democracy should handle
this I the hospital thing the hospital
thing is a little tricky
because in the moment I can understand
that someone would blame Israel for that
bombing you know when the when that
story broke it was Israel destroys
hospital with 500 people dead turned out
Hospital wasn't destroyed New York Times
ran a photograph of a destroyed building
it wasn't the hospital uh turns out the
parking lot of the hospital was struck a
lot of cars were burned uh I don't know
if anybody died maybe a few people which
very sad uh but it probably wasn't by
Israel so in the first half hour hour
five 5 hours you could maybe have leapt
to the wrong conclusion when it came
pretty clear that it wasn't the case
forget who did it forget whether Israel
did it or whether it was uh Islamic
Jihad missile that did it
uh it wasn't 500 people it wasn't a
hospital destroyed why wouldn't you fix
that and she stood up at a rally the
next day and said some things are
probably not true it's embarrassing for
her again let her constituents put her
out of office and if they agree with her
or like what she says anyway you know
it's hard to disagree they can let them
do what they do one thing that you
alluded to earlier um is this question
of what the US relationship with Israel
ought to look like and this is something
I think about a lot because sometimes I
get frustrated with our fellow traveler
Libertarians for I think sometimes
seeming a little unrealistic on matters
of foreign policy I think there's
frequently a sense of what the US should
do aspirationally but then there also
needs to be a sense of what the US
should do in order to taper off an
existing relationship recognizing that
you know cutting off ties or cutting off
any sort of funding of Israel is not
something that can realistically happen
overnight and that there would be
massive second order consequences that
would stem from that if that did happen
how do you look at this relationship
between the US and Israel and and this
us support for isra
how do you look at it aspirationally in
terms of what that relationship ought to
be like but also more practically uh
it's a tricky question um I know it's a
big question and you're not a foreign
policy expert but I'm just curious about
how your views on this have evolved over
time was I'm not an expert but I often
play one on TV so I'll do the best I can
um the United States gives about three
billion I think dollars a year to Israel
give a similar amount to Egypt uh at
least until recently
maybe uh that is not free money it is
credits it's three billion dollars of
credits that the U that um Israel has to
use in the US military grocery store
meaning it's for purchasing Us weapons
aircraft Etc uh so it it is a um a
subsidy both to Israel and the US uh
defense industry defense industry and
um historically I've never been in favor
of that Aid uh I've always opposed it I
don't think it's good for Israel
particularly we're now a very rich
country when it was first started we
were pretty poor country Israel has a
pretty high standard of living we can
pay for our own equipment if we want I'm
happy I hope the US will continue to
sell it to us I think the trickier part
of the relationship is
um what's happening right now so right
now uh there two aircraft carers uh in
the Eastern side of the
Mediterranean and a nuclear submarine
and they're there mainly to threaten
Iran and Iran's uh friend Hezbollah and
to say don't think about opening up a
second front against Israel or we'll
punish
you um that's been really helpful to us
more or less here in Israel it's not
clear whether we we do a nuclear weapon
here
um that carries a lot of weight but it's
a threat you never want to carry out
so I don't know what this would look
like right now if the US had not made
that implicit threat and I'm sure they
made some explicit threats behind the
scenes that we don't know about so
that's very helpful to Israel uh having
said that I I think it's a legitimate
question for Americans to ask whether
that serves the interest of the United
States there are many Jews Evangelical
Christians and others who see Israel in
a very special light different from many
other other
countries but whether the average uh
American taxpayer should be
funding the uh ability of the United
States to still act as something of the
world's placement I think is a is a
complicated question if Israel had to
stand on its
own uh it would have to devote a lot
more of its resources to the mil its own
military which it devotes a significant
amount already but it would have to
devote more
and it was set in motion a whole bunch
of things some of them would be good for
Israel and some not so good uh a lot of
people would argue that this moment has
taught us that Israel cannot defend
itself alone that it needs the United
States to be a counterweight to to Iran
and that may be true so I I think it's
going to be very interesting to see how
this evolves over the next few
years um and whether any President Biden
who are whoever wins uh the next
election would carry out threats like uh
that are being implied against Iran and
risk a world war with with Russia which
is Iran's um Ally and and the rest of
the Middle East it's
um it's pretty um pretty challenging
yeah you know what concerns me about the
relationship between the US and Israel a
it's not an unconditional support but it
is a very
substantial like we've got your back
kind of thing and and I'm I'm morally
supportive of the right of Israel's
government to defend its people against
this kind of atrocity and to seek
Justice and rescue the hostages and
dismantle Hamas to the extent that can
be done what I've been uncomfortable
with and become increasingly so is any
us Aid in that project because Israel's
military is having to make really
difficult moral calculations and
tradeoffs about how many soldiers
they're willing to sacrifice in ground
operations versus how many civilian
casualties to accept with other types of
you know aerial bombings and they're not
easy calls and frankly they're not
always calls that I agree with and the
more the US has culpability in that with
its its funding you know the worst all
around on all sides that is in my view
it it's it's Israel's fight and the
government of Israel is is seems capable
of Prosecuting it and I wonder when
you're talking about you know the the
difference in Israel's interests and
America's
interests is
America do you do you you think America
is in some sense
tying Israel's hands in ways that makes
it harder to defend itself well it cuts
both ways right
um I think America's Embrace of Israel
the government's embrace the military
abrace of Israel is um has costs for the
United States uh those costs may be
worth bearing for other benefits they
may be worth bearing for moral
reasons it's not an easy question
question to answer I would just add that
a friend of mine said the other day that
the Embrace of the United States of
Israel is more like a bear
hug it um it doesn't just show love and
affection it also constrains Israel a
great deal uh many of those constraints
we would impose on ourselves here
certainly with respect to civilian
casualties but uh historically often
Israel
has gone along with what the United
States wanted because
there's a feeling here that we need the
United States so we couldn't rely on
that we would behave differently and
that would be both good and bad I
suspect Russ Roberts thank you so much
for talking to reason I'm pretty sure
most of our viewers and listeners
already know where they can find you um
but in case they don't where can people
find you and uh read more of your
thoughts and and hear more of them as
well uh my substack on my experiences
here in Israel is called listening to
the sir you can find that at substack um
I archive all my work at Russ roberts.
info and of course my podcast is econ
talk which you can find at any uh place
where good P good podcasts are sold
although ours is given away so enjoy it
without charge thank you so much we
really appreciate